[Music]
so
[Music]
whoop
i totally meant to do that
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and we
finally have new ipods you might not be
able to tell unless you were following
this stuff in fact you wouldn't even see
it if you went to apple.com it's not on
the tabs up top but it's a two-year-old
long overdue refresh of the new ipod
touch and this is everything you need to
know that's new about it so first new
thing is the updated specs so this new
ipod touch is rocking an apple a8 chip
and one gigabyte of ram and this was the
most needed part of the refresh so now
the benchmarks are a little bit below
the current iphone which is great and
performance all around is zippy and
smooth just like the experience on a
fresh iphone or previous ipad touches as
you would expect we all know ios handles
one gigabyte of ram pretty well so it's
still smooth and even gaming is great on
this ipod and actually think that's
where it's going to end up being the
best reason to buy this i wish the
screen was a little bit bigger but while
a lot of us 90s kids grew up with game
boys and psps i could see someone buying
this in 2015 as their first handheld
gaming console so think about that now
speaking of the display that's actually
the second major new thing so it's
rocking a four inch retina display so 11
36 by 640 at 326 pixels per inch nothing
too crazy here like i said i wish it was
a little bit bigger but you know for
watching videos and gaming it's all
right and again it's still an ipod so
it's a media player it's something you
want to keep small and portable and
believe me they have done exactly that
this thing is still super thin and light
at 6.1 millimeters thin and 88 grams but
it's still solid as a rock still so no
bend gate issues here the ipod touch is
built very well and in this really thin
body they managed to fit two other new
pieces of hardware first is the very
slightly larger battery this newest one
is rocking 1043 milliamp hour battery
where the last ipod touch was a 1030
milliamp hour battery so just a little
tiny bit bigger but you'll actually see
more of the battery life improvements
thanks to new software and the new specs
and the other thing that's new is the
new camera so now you're set with a new
8 megapixel camera with an f 2.4
aperture it's essentially on par with
the iphone 5's camera in fact i think a
lot of the parts like the camera here
and the display
come from the iphone five so it was top
of the line a few years ago now it's
come a lot down in price makes sense for
apple to finish out the stock of these
parts so the photos and videos will look
pretty good and yes it does protrude a
little bit from the back i wish it
didn't but oh well lastly one thing
that's not actually new
is the home button which is kind of
disappointing since that means there's
no touch id and also there's no nfc so
no apple pay no unlocking your phone
with your fingerprint no touching it to
pay for apps etc kind of wish it would
have been there it would have been nice
to have but it's not here just a regular
home button also that strap that used to
be connected to the back of the ipod to
hold it to your wrist that's gone too so
it starts at 200 bucks even for the 16
gig and i think that's a pretty good
start even the 32 gig is probably a good
deal but i think once you go over that
you're getting into iphone price
territory so at that point i'd probably
not recommend it i'd actually say to get
an iphone i also highly recommend this
blue color but it also now comes in
silver gold space gray pink and red so
there you have it it's that simple
that's the 2015 ipod touch
at the end of the day it's kind of hard
to say who exactly this is for like who
the typical customer of this is but it's
basically someone who wants an iphone
but can't have an iphone so wants to get
all the same experiences like it kind of
reminds me of minor cousins they're
about 10 years old right now shout out
to john and rj if you're watching this
uh they can't have an iphone right now
but they still can get something like
this which is a lot cheaper and has
pretty much all the same pros of ios and
all the games and apps that they like so
that's essentially who it's for so there
you have it thank you for watching this
video feel free to hit that like button
below if you enjoyed or even better
there's a subscribe button below that if
you want to see more videos like this
also uh i i don't need this one anymore
i have an iphone that i use and i listen
to apple music on it so i don't need
this ipod so i'm gonna go ahead and give
this one away
so to enter to win this exact ipod below
that like button there's a comment
section if you're a subscriber just go
ahead and leave a comment letting me
know you want to win and i'll pick one
random winner from anywhere in the world
in one week and announce that winner's
name on twitter so go ahead and stay
tuned there that's it thanks for
watching and good luck peace